This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Back in 2003, Emily Nussbaum developed a covert guilty pleasure. I had a bad habit of watching the streaming 24-hour feeds of the first season of Big Brother in the U.S., which is something that I was doing pretty much every day and talking to nobody about because it was extremely embarrassing. Big Brother is a reality television show that debuted in the U.S. in the year 2000. If you've never seen it, the show is basically about a group of people who are isolated in a house that's under constant surveillance, and one contestant gets voted out each week. For Emily,
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。早在2003年，艾米丽·努斯鲍姆就养成了一种隐秘的罪恶快感。我当时有个坏习惯，就是每天都在看美国第一季《老大哥》的24小时直播流，这几乎是我每天都在做的事情，而且我没跟任何人提起，因为这实在太尴尬了。《老大哥》是一档2000年在美国首播的真人秀节目。如果你没看过，这档节目的基本内容就是一群人被隔离在一所处于持续监控下的房子里，每周会有一名选手被投票淘汰。对于艾米丽来说，
it was a sort of comfort watch. They just showed the people in this house in California 24-7, and so I would put them in the corner of my screen. I would wake up in New York, and I'd watch them sleeping out in California. In the early 2000s, reality shows like Big Brother and Survivor were beginning to conquer network and cable television.
这是一种慰藉式的观看。他们只是全天候展示加州这所房子里的人，所以我会在屏幕角落放着他们。我在纽约醒来时，会看着他们在加州睡觉。在21世纪初，像《老大哥》和《幸存者》这样的真人秀开始征服电视网和有线电视。
Emily was one of millions of Americans submitting to the unscripted TV takeover. It's interesting to see regular people. It's interesting to see regular people. It's interesting to see authentic behavior by real people put under pressure. I think this is a universal appeal of all of these shows, however you define them. And people can criticize that and say that that's cruel and voyeuristic to want to watch regular people under pressure. But I also think it is human nature.
艾米丽是数百万屈服于无剧本电视接管的美国人之一。观察普通人很有趣。观察普通人很有趣。观察真实的人在压力下表现出的真实行为很有趣。我认为这是所有这些节目的普遍吸引力，无论你如何定义它们。人们可以批评这一点，说想要观看处于压力下的普通人是残忍和窥淫癖的表现。但我同时也认为这是人性。
At the time, Emily was a freelance writer in search of a book idea. And she had the thought that maybe she could turn her slightly cringey habit into a book about reality TV. And I said this to this friend of mine, and he said, well, you better write that fast. And his idea was, this is a gimmick. This is a trend and it's going gonna die within a very short time, and by the time you write a book on it, it'll be gone. Clearly, that prediction did not come to pass.
当时，艾米丽是一名正在寻找书籍创意的自由撰稿人。她想也许可以把自己这个有点令人尴尬的习惯变成一本关于真人秀的书。我跟一位朋友说了这个想法，他说，那你最好快点写。他的观点是，这只是个噱头。这是一种潮流，很快就会消亡，等你写完书的时候，它就已经不存在了。显然，那个预测并没有成真。
Is this chicken what I have, or is this fish? It's raw, you f***ing idiot! I was rooting for you, we were all rooting for you! I'm not here to make friends. You know, I'm not here to make friends. I'm not here to make friends. I'm here for one reason. Not only did reality TV survive, it exploded into an industry so powerful that it transformed
我吃的是鸡肉还是鱼？这是生的，你这个该死的白痴！我一直支持你，我们都在支持你！我来这里不是为了交朋友。你知道，我来这里不是为了交朋友。我来这里不是为了交朋友。我来这里只有一个原因。真人秀不仅存活了下来，还爆发成了一个强大的产业，以至于它改变了
American society and politics. 20-something years later, Emily Nussbaum did write that book. It's called Cue the Sun, the Invention of Reality TV. I have to confess, I really hate reality television. It's shocking, I know. But I I really hate reality television. It's shocking, I know. But I did really love this book. I talked to Emily about the early history of this controversial form of entertainment, its decades-long creation process, how it shapes our world, and why, love it or hate
美国社会和政治。20多年后，艾米丽·努斯鲍姆确实写了那本书。书名叫《Cue the Sun, the Invention of Reality TV》。我必须承认，我真的很讨厌真人秀。我知道这很令人震惊。但我真的真的很讨厌真人秀。我知道这很令人震惊。但我确实非常喜欢这本书。我和艾米丽聊了这种充满争议的娱乐形式的早期历史、它长达数十年的创作过程、它如何塑造我们的世界，以及为什么，无论你爱它还是恨它，
it, you should have for reality television is that it's not authentic, that it's not real. What is your response to something like that? Well, for one thing, that's correct. Is it real? It depends on what show you're talking about. And one of the things I think is appealing to people about the genre is often there's sort of a nugget of authenticity inside something very contrived.
你对真人秀应该有的看法是它不真实，它不是真的。你对这样的说法有什么回应？嗯，首先，这是正确的。它是真的吗？这取决于你在谈论哪档节目。我认为人们对这种类型感兴趣的原因之一，往往是在非常刻意的东西里包含了一点点真实。
The way I define reality television in my book is as what I call dirty documentary, which is, you know, a term I chose specifically because of the dirty part of it. It's not a pure genre. It's not a pure art form in any way. Reality television is what happens when somebody takes the tools of documentary, which people consider very esteemed, prestigious, you know, high-minded notions of cinema verite. You just hold a camera and you hold up a microphone and you just watch and you wait for truth to emerge. And then what you do is you cut it with something else. You cut it with a
我在书中将真人秀定义为我所谓的“肮脏纪录片”，你知道，我之所以选择这个词，正是因为其中的“肮脏”部分。它不是一种纯粹的类型。它在任何方面都不是一种纯粹的艺术形式。真人秀是当有人采用了纪录片的工具时所产生的结果，人们认为纪录片是非常受人尊敬、享有盛誉的，你知道，是电影真实主义的高尚理念。你只是拿着摄像机，举着麦克风，然后观察并等待真相浮现。然后你所做的是把它和其他东西剪辑在一起。你把它与一种
commercial format that will speed things up, put pressure on people, and guarantee responses. And there are all sorts of ways of doing this. And what I trace in this book is the history of people doing this experiment, which is essentially combining cinema verite documentary with game shows, combining it with prank shows, combining it with soap opera. Just all sorts of attempts to essentially speed it up and make it more intense. In your book you talk about how since its inception, reality television has always been a lightning rod for criticism and that people have always had
商业模式剪辑在一起，这种模式会加快节奏，给人们施加压力，并确保得到回应。有很多方法可以做到这一点。我在书中追溯了人们进行这种实验的历史，这本质上是将电影真实主义纪录片与游戏节目、恶作剧节目、肥皂剧相结合。这只是各种试图从本质上加快节奏并使其更具冲击力的尝试。在你的书中，你谈到自诞生以来，真人秀一直是批评的避雷针，而且人们一直对
these mixed feelings about the morality of this form of entertainment, even before television itself existed. Could you talk about that? One of the biggest surprises to me in researching this book was that the freakout over reality television not only wasn't modern, but it had happened before. In the late 40s, there was this emergence of a type of radio that was new that used regular people.
这种娱乐形式的道德性有着复杂的感受，甚至在电视本身出现之前就是如此。你能谈谈这个吗？在研究这本书时，我最大的惊喜之一是，对真人秀的恐慌不仅不是现代才有的，而且以前也发生过。在40年代末，出现了一种使用普通人的新型广播节目。
And at the time, they called it audience participation radio. There were all sorts of shows like this. There were game shows, there were competition shows, there were confession shows, there were shows that were sort of humiliating. And people responded to these shows in a way that was almost an exact parallel to the way they responded to, say, Survivor at the turn of the century. There were articles essentially saying, who are these people? Why are these people
当时，他们称之为“观众参与广播”。有各种各样的这类节目。有游戏节目、竞赛节目、忏悔节目，还有一些带有羞辱性质的节目。人们对这些节目的反应方式，几乎与他们在世纪之交对《幸存者》的反应完全平行。当时的文章基本上都在说，这些人是谁？为什么这些人
going on the radio? What does this mean about our culture? Is there suddenly a rise in narcissism? This is embarrassing and shameful. Why are people listening to these shows? And there were also the legitimate complaints saying these shows are cheap, exploitative, and tawdry, and they're ruining radio because they're not paying anyone. Right. Because these shows from the beginning were created to get around labor unions. Yes. The people who created these shows had multiple motives. Some of them were straightforwardly budgetary. Like, reality TV has always been a way to make inexpensive stories without paying writers and without paying actors. It's a strikebreaker. It's an ununionized thing.
要上广播？这对我们的文化意味着什么？自恋情绪突然抬头了吗？这太尴尬、太可耻了。为什么人们要听这些节目？还有一些合理的抱怨，说这些节目廉价、剥削且庸俗，它们正在毁掉广播，因为它们不给任何人报酬。没错。因为这些节目从一开始就是为了绕过工会而创建的。是的。创建这些节目的人有多种动机。其中一些纯粹是出于预算考虑。比如，真人秀一直是一种制作低成本故事的方式，无需支付编剧和演员费用。它是破坏罢工的工具。它是不受工会约束的东西。
That was true from the first shows I talked about. You wrote about a morally questionable show called Candid Microphone, which was created by a morally questionable guy named Alan Fundt. How did that show come about? Candid Microphone was created by Fundt for the reason a lot of these things were created,
这在我谈到的第一批节目中就是事实。你写了一档道德上有问题的节目叫《隐藏的麦克风》，它是由一个叫艾伦·芬特（Alan Funt）的道德上有问题的人创建的。那档节目是怎么产生的？《隐藏的麦克风》是芬特为了许多这类节目被创建的原因而创建的，
which is a technological breakthrough, which was the invention of the portable tape recorder. And Alan Fund, given his personality, I feel like he is an American Titan. He was also a complete ass-and-kind of a brutal guy. But I think that his willingness to cross lines, his first thought when he saw the portable tape recorder was, I can tape people without them knowing it. And I can record them without permission. These are the kind of people whose names were never very important and probably never will
那就是技术突破，即便携式录音机的发明。而艾伦·芬特，考虑到他的个性，我觉得他是一位美国巨人。他也是个彻头彻尾的混蛋，是个相当粗暴的人。但我认为他愿意跨越界限，他看到便携式录音机时的第一个想法是，我可以在人们不知情的情况下录下他们。我可以在未经许可的情况下录下他们。这些人名字从未显得很重要，可能永远也不会
be. These are the words they spoke when faced with something unexpected in their daily lives. And they never knew you would hear them because they never knew they were talking into the candid microphone. Among the things that Alan Fund created was the entire role of the reality producer, which is to say a person who didn't just stand behind a camera and watch or tell you where to go, but actually messed with you. His initial goal actually was just to record conversations. He bugged soda straws at a diner counter to record the models from upstairs talking
重要。当他们在日常生活中面对意想不到的事情时，他们说出了这些话。他们永远不知道你会听到，因为他们不知道自己正在对着隐藏的麦克风说话。艾伦·芬特创造的东西中，包括了真人秀制作人的整个角色，也就是说，这个人不仅仅站在摄像机后面观察或告诉你去哪里，而是真的在捉弄你。他最初的目标其实只是录制对话。他在餐馆柜台的苏打吸管里安装了窃听器，以录制楼上的模特们谈论
about things. And then, you know, he bugged all sorts of places. He bugged maternity wards and playgrounds. I mean, it's really kind of crazy. But he decided that the conversations that were overheard were not interesting enough to put on the radio. And what you really needed was a different kind of producer. You needed a provocateur.
事情。然后，你知道，他在各种地方都装了窃听器。他在产房和操场上都装了窃听器。我的意思是，这真的很疯狂。但他认为偷听到的对话不足以放在广播里播出。你真正需要的是另一种制作人。你需要一个煽动者。
And he realized this is what will make a segment work, is I have to mess with somebody. I have to throw off their sense of what's real and what's normal that will create humor, that will create shock. And he perfected this over the course of the show. Let's call this locksmith Joe. This day he walked into my office
他意识到这就是让片段奏效的方法，我必须捉弄某人。我必须打破他们对什么是真实、什么是正常的认知，这会制造幽默，制造震惊。他在节目过程中完善了这一点。我们称这位锁匠为乔。这一天他走进我的办公室，
and answered to a routine call to open a lock. He found the lock was on a heavy chain and the chain was used to bind my secretary's leg to the desk at which she worked calmly. Handed microphone was strange enough that it actually unsettled the critics. So one of the main critics I write about watched it and initially he loved it. He was like, this is a really sophisticated show. It's like peeking through keyholes and it gives you access to so much human behavior
响应了一个常规的开锁电话。他发现锁在一根沉重的铁链上，而铁链被用来将我秘书的腿绑在她工作的桌子上。她很冷静。《隐藏的麦克风》足够奇怪，以至于它实际上让评论家们感到不安。所以我写到的主要评论家之一观看了它，起初他很喜欢。他说，这是一档非常复杂的节目。就像透过钥匙孔窥视，它让你接触到如此多的人类行为，
because he was recording people secretly and pulling all these pranks on them. And then later that same critic was horrified by the show and was like, wait, this is the beginning of the end for everybody because it's intrinsically cruel. It exposes people. It makes me very uncomfortable. Now we're gonna start tonight's program
因为他秘密录制人们并对他们进行各种恶作剧。后来，同一位评论家对这档节目感到恐惧，他说，等等，这是所有人的末日开始，因为它本质上是残忍的。它暴露了人们。这让我非常不舒服。现在我们要开始今晚的节目，
with two very dangerous questions. But Candid Microphone was popular enough that Funt was eventually able to transfer it to television with Candid Camera. The questions are, what is a lady's age and her weight? Now those are two things that most ladies feel are nobody else's business but our own. But unless you're very brave,
带着两个非常危险的问题。但《隐藏的麦克风》非常受欢迎，以至于芬特最终能够将其转移到电视上，变成了《隐藏的摄像机》。问题是，女士的年龄和体重是多少？现在，这是大多数女士认为除了自己之外谁都不关心的两件事。但除非你非常勇敢，
don't pop these two questions. We did with the following results. How old are you and how much do you weigh? And how many times have you had your face swiped asking that question? No one swiped me yet. You mean people actually tell you? Sure.
否则别问这两个问题。我们问了，结果如下。你多大了，体重多少？你问这个问题时，有多少次被人扇耳光？还没人扇过我。你是说人们真的告诉你了？当然。
What kind of a survey is this? I'll tell you after you give me your answer. See, just all we need is your age and weight. That's simple. That's nothing. I'm 54. We're 140. Can you talk about that moment, the smile you're on candid camera, and what it's doing to make this sort of thing that could be uncomfortable palatable to a person who might just reject the whole reality TV premise.
这是什么调查？在你给出答案后我会告诉你。看，我们只需要你的年龄和体重。很简单。那没什么。我54岁。140磅。你能谈谈那一刻吗，那个“你在隐藏的摄像机里”的微笑，以及它是如何让这种可能令人不舒服的事情变得让那些可能拒绝整个真人秀前提的人也能接受的？
Well, that part was added after it went on television. Like this is the beginning of television, you know, and the show ran for several decades. But in the early years, it was actually very hard to transfer it to TV because once you could see a person's face being tricked, it made it much more uncomfortable for the audience. He developed these techniques of handling audience response, because you make people too uncomfortable, they won't want to watch.
嗯，那部分是在它上电视后添加的。就像这是电视的开端，你知道，这档节目播出了几十年。但在早期，实际上很难将其转移到电视上，因为一旦你能看到一个人的脸被戏弄，这会让观众感到更加不舒服。他发展出了处理观众反应的技术，因为如果你让人们感到太不舒服，他们就不想看了。
You have to ease it for them in certain ways. So they added the theme song, which I think a lot of people know, where it's like, smile, you're on candid camera. When the police expected, you're elected. You're the star today. Smile. You're on candid camera.
你必须以某种方式让他们感到轻松。所以他们添加了主题曲，我想很多人都知道，就像是，“微笑，你在隐藏的摄像机里”。当警察预料到时，你被选中了。你是今天的主角。微笑。你在隐藏的摄像机里。
Honestly, first of all, it's incredibly catchy. Brought me right back when I listened to it. But also, the song expresses the philosophy, which is essentially that the song is a form of gaslighting. It's basically saying, like, you might think you've been pranked, but actually this is a huge compliment. And if you complain about it, it's because you're uptight and you don't get jokes. You know, it basically says by being selected to appear on candid camera, you have become a celebrity. You should be happy and complimented. Your feelings shouldn't be hurt.
老实说，首先，它非常朗朗上口。我听的时候立刻把我带回了过去。但同时，这首歌表达了一种哲学，本质上这首歌是一种煤气灯效应。它基本上是在说，你可能认为你被恶作剧了，但实际上这是一个巨大的恭维。如果你对此抱怨，那是因为你太紧张了，不懂幽默。你知道，它基本上是在说，被选中出现在《隐藏的摄像机》里，你已经成为了名人。你应该感到高兴和被恭维。你的感情不应该受到伤害。
You shouldn't feel wounded and you shouldn't feel vulnerable. And so it's a former propaganda for the itself, and it cheers the audience up and makes them feel like, you know, you're safe to watch this. He also created this thing that he called the reveal, which is that moment that he says, smile, you're on candid camera. He would ease their pain, because he would say, oh no, you're on camera, this is all a joke. My age is, oh, I have to think, I was just 38.
你不应该感到受伤，也不应该感到脆弱。所以它是节目本身的宣传形式，它让观众振作起来，让他们觉得，你知道，看这个是安全的。他还创造了他所谓的“揭秘”，也就是他说“微笑，你在隐藏的摄像机里”的那一刻。他会减轻他们的痛苦，因为他会说，哦不，你在摄像机里，这都是个玩笑。我的年龄是，哦，我得想想，我刚38岁。
And your weight? And my weight is 144. Is it okay if the whole country knows this? I don't care. Okay, if you don't care, we'll put it on television then. It's candid camera. So there were a lot of the show that people found really stimulating and psychologically interesting and there were other parts that seemed cruel and sadistic.
那你的体重呢？我的体重是144磅。如果全国都知道这个没关系吗？我不在乎。好的，如果你不在乎，那我们就把它放在电视上播。这是《隐藏的摄像机》。所以节目中有很多人们觉得非常刺激和心理上有趣的部分，也有其他看起来残忍和虐待狂的部分。
It was that mixture and the fact that you couldn't really separate the two that made the show so powerful and made it the beginning of the genre. So the prank show and Alan Funt were sort of the early origins of the genre. So the prank show and Alan Font were sort of the early origins of the genre. And a decade or so later, this next phase of proto-reality television is the game show, which was revolutionized by a different problematic man. Can you tell me about Chuck Barris? So Chuck Barris is the guy who made the dating game, the newlywed game, and the Gong show. And for a while during the late 60s and throughout the 70s,
正是这种混合，以及你无法真正将两者分开的事实，使得这档节目如此强大，并使其成为该类型的开端。所以恶作剧节目和艾伦·芬特算是该类型的早期起源。所以恶作剧节目和艾伦·芬特算是该类型的早期起源。大约十年后，原型真人秀的下一个阶段是游戏节目，它被另一个有问题的人彻底改变了。你能跟我说说查克·巴里斯（Chuck Barris）吗？所以查克·巴里斯是制作了《约会游戏》、《新婚游戏》和《锣声秀》的人。在60年代末和整个70年代，
he was kind of the schlock king of Hollywood, and he was much hated by everybody else in television for several reasons. Now, ladies and gentlemen, here's your host in the start of our show, the ultra-superfluous Mr. Chuck Berry. One of them is they felt like the stuff he was doing was garbage and exploitative, but mainly because he was making so much money and his company was really flying high. It's Gong Show time again, folks.
他算是好莱坞的垃圾之王，而且他被电视界的其他人所憎恨，原因有几个。现在，女士们先生们，这是我们的主持人，我们节目的开场，超级多余的查克·巴里斯先生。其中一个原因是他们觉得他做的事情是垃圾和剥削性的，但主要是因为他赚了太多的钱，他的公司真的飞黄腾达了。又是《锣声秀》时间了，伙计们。
All right, now it's our policy to try and show you a variety of entertainment. So right after today's show, stick around. We'll be demonstrating the lost art of setting trash cans on fire. He was a really wacky, weird guy. And I will say that when I talked to the people who worked with Chuck Barris, unlike the people that I read things about who worked with Alan Fundt, they loved him.
好了，现在我们的政策是尽量向你们展示各种娱乐节目。所以今天的节目结束后，留下来。我们将演示点燃垃圾桶的失传艺术。他是个非常古怪、奇怪的人。我得说，当我采访那些和查克·巴里斯一起工作的人时，与我读到的关于艾伦·芬特工作过的人不同，他们爱他。
They loved working at that company, partially because they experienced what I think a lot of people in reality TV have experienced, that they were kind of punk outsiders in Hollywood, entertaining by any means necessary. Like, they found it really fun. It was kind of a decadent, crazy, 70s thing. I mean, there's a million things to say about Chuck Barris. He's a complicated character. But the other thing is Chuck Baris got big by making the dating game, which was this ridiculous sort of silly game in which hot people would be, like a woman would be on one side of a wall and on the other side would
他们喜欢在那家公司工作，部分原因是他们经历了我想很多真人秀从业者都经历过的事情，那就是他们是好莱坞的朋克局外人，不惜一切代价进行娱乐。就像，他们觉得这真的很有趣。这是一种颓废、疯狂的70年代风格。我的意思是，关于查克·巴里斯有无数话要说。他是一个复杂的人物。但另一件事是，查克·巴里斯通过制作《约会游戏》而走红，这是一种荒谬的、愚蠢的游戏，火辣的人会，比如一个女人会站在墙的一边，而另一边会有
be three bachelors and she would flirt with them making various stupid sex jokes and stuff like that. He actually ripped the show off from an earlier audience participation show that was called Blind Date. So Chuck Barrett essentially repurposed a lot of the shows from the 40s and 50s, and then he sexed them up and made them kind of mod with splashy flowers and increasingly dirty jokes. So that was really his gift on TV. I imagine if you scripted some of these raunchy lines,
三个单身汉，她会和他们调情，开各种愚蠢的性玩笑之类的。他实际上是从一个更早的观众参与节目《盲目约会》中抄袭了这个节目。所以查克·巴里斯本质上重新利用了40和50年代的许多节目，然后他给它们增加了性元素，并用华丽的花朵和越来越下流的笑话使它们变得时髦。所以这确实是他在电视上的天赋。我想如果你编写了一些这些下流的台词，
they wouldn't get through network sensors. But because regular people were saying unexpected and often boundary pushing things more spontaneously, the shows got away with a lot and kept people's attention as a result. I mean, honestly, just making things dirty is kind of a cheap way of intensifying things. I do feel like he had this one tool and he used it over and over again.
它们是无法通过电视网审查的。但因为普通人在更自发地说出意想不到且经常挑战底线的话，这些节目逃脱了很多审查，结果也保持了人们的注意力。我的意思是，老实说，只是让事情变得下流是一种加强节目的廉价方式。我确实觉得他有这一个工具，并且他一遍又一遍地使用它。
A lot of these shows really were about moving the line between private and public. I mean, that's the nature of reality TV is allowing you to peer into somebody's private world. Sometimes in a contrived way, sometimes because they're just confessing. The show that was interesting was The Newlywed Game. What Spanish word or phrase will your wife say best describes her bust? Jimmy? Nada. The Newlywed Game really did use ordinary couples and had them talk about their sex lives. It was often a very sexist show. The jokes were really stupid. But yeah, it was exciting and titillating and strange to see people
很多这些节目确实是关于移动私人和公共之间的界限。我的意思是，这就是真人秀的本质，让你窥视某人的私人世界。有时是以一种刻意的方式，有时是因为他们只是在忏悔。那档有趣的节目是《新婚游戏》。你的妻子会用什么西班牙语单词或短语来最好地描述她的胸部？吉米？Nada（没有）。《新婚游戏》确实使用了普通夫妇，并让他们谈论他们的性生活。这通常是一档非常性别歧视的节目。笑话真的很愚蠢。但是的，看到人们
treat their own early marriages like pinatas and like bash them open and show their conflicts and their little sex jokes, their nicknames for one another. And one of the reasons that show was green-lighted was they were initially thinking of doing it with celebrities actually and they had a regular couple on and the executives for the network were Genuinely riveted by the sight of this cute young newlywed couple just giggling and saying silly things Mm-hmm. I mean, I think that's at the heart of it It was the idea of peeking inside somebody's marriages and I think the period that I'm tracing in reality TV
把他们自己的早期婚姻当作皮纳塔（piñata）一样对待，把它们砸开，展示他们的冲突和他们的小性玩笑，他们给彼此起的绰号，这很令人兴奋、挑逗且奇怪。而那档节目获准播出的原因之一是，他们最初其实是想用名人来做，但他们请了一对普通夫妇，电视网的高管们被这对可爱的年轻新婚夫妇只是咯咯笑并说些傻话的样子深深吸引了。嗯，我的意思是，我认为这是核心所在。这是窥视某人婚姻的想法，我认为我在真人秀中追溯的时期
traces the gradual movement through many means like political, through people writing more memoirs, people talking about, all sorts of things like consciousness raising groups in the 70s for feminists. All of these things encouraged people to tell private stories in public and this was a huge shock to the world. And reality TV was only one part of that, but I think they're all a little bit woven together. Let's talk about the sort of the form that I think begins to look like what we see today,
追溯了通过许多手段（如政治手段，通过人们写更多的回忆录，人们谈论各种事情，比如70年代女权主义者的意识提升小组）的逐渐运动。所有这些事情都鼓励人们在公共场合讲述私人故事，这对世界来说是一个巨大的冲击。真人秀只是其中的一部分，但我认为它们都交织在一起。让我们谈谈那种我认为开始看起来像我们今天所见的形式，
but also has a little bit more of a documentary edge, is the real-life soap opera of American Family. This is the home of the William C. Loud family. The Louds are neither average nor typical. No family is. They are not the American family. They are simply an American family. An American Family premiered in 1973. This is one of the shows that only older people who read this book will have heard of the show. Because it's been
但也有一点纪录片色彩的，就是《美国家庭》的现实生活肥皂剧。这是威廉·C·劳德（William C. Loud）一家的家。劳德一家既不普通也不典型。没有哪个家庭是典型的。他们不是“美国家庭”。他们只是一个美国家庭。《美国家庭》于1973年首播。这是只有读过这本书的老年人才会听说过的节目之一。因为它已经被
kind of wiped out of history, but it's extremely important to the book. Basically what it was is, unlike a out of history but it's extremely important to the book. Basically what it was is unlike a lot of other shows that were on cable or network, it was a PBS show and it was a documentary about a family that was filmed in 1971 in Santa Barbara, California and the family was the Louds. They were a wealthy family, Bill and Pat Loud and their five children. And over the course of them filming it, over seven months, Pat asked Bill for a divorce on camera.
从历史上抹去了，但它对这本书非常重要。基本上，它与许多其他在有线电视或电视网上播出的节目不同，它是一档PBS节目，是一部关于1971年在加州圣巴巴拉拍摄的家庭的纪录片，这个家庭就是劳德一家。他们是一个富裕的家庭，比尔和帕特·劳德以及他们的五个孩子。在他们拍摄的七个月过程中，帕特在镜头前向比尔提出了离婚。
And their oldest son was Lance Loud, who was a 19 year old, incredibly charismatic, louche funny, openly gay, artistic guy who was living in the Chelsea Hotel for a while in New York. The site on television of a woman going through a divorce and an openly gay teenage son who was in a close relationship with his mom just blew people's minds and it became a show that everyone talked about when it came out in 1973. A lot of people were horrified by it for the reasons they've always been horrified by reality
他们的大儿子是兰斯·劳德（Lance Loud），一个19岁、极具魅力、放荡、有趣、公开出柜、有艺术气息的家伙，他在纽约的切尔西酒店住了一段时间。电视上出现一个女人经历离婚和一个公开出柜的十几岁儿子与他母亲保持亲密关系的画面，让人们大开眼界，它成为了1973年播出时每个人都在谈论的节目。很多人对它感到恐惧，原因和他们一直对真人秀实验感到恐惧的原因一样，
experiments which is why are the people putting their dirty laundry out in public? Who are these ordinary people who are suddenly famous people? So the way I put it is it was created in honestly kind of a high-minded way with this idea of we're creating a cinema verite documentary, but the way people received it was as a reality show. And it really was the first reality soap opera. It was like a real-life soap opera and it the first reality soap opera. It was like a real life soap opera and it destabilized the culture. It also turned the Louds themselves into the first genuine reality stars. Lance Loud really was the first gay man on television who was openly gay in this particular way.
那就是为什么人们要把他们的脏衣服在公共场合晾晒？这些突然成名的普通人是谁？所以我这样说，它是在一种相当高尚的方式下创作的，带着“我们正在创作一部电影真实主义纪录片”的想法，但人们接收到的方式却是一档真人秀。它确实是第一部现实生活肥皂剧。它就像一部现实生活中的肥皂剧，它动摇了文化。它还把劳德一家变成了第一批真正的真人秀明星。兰斯·劳德确实是电视上第一个以这种特定方式公开出柜的男同性恋者。
Sometimes I think of myself as the perfect combination of non-existence because I really can't see how other people exist other than my way of life. But the other thing Lance Loud is is he's the first really self-consciously confident reality star. Unlike the rest of his family, Lance was down for this project. Like he loved the idea of doing this kind of arch performance of self. I love to live, you know, with a style and a certain phony put on elegance. I mean, what can I say?
有时我把自己看作是不存在的完美结合，因为我真的看不出其他人除了我的生活方式之外是如何存在的。但兰斯·劳德的另一面是，他是第一个非常有自我意识、自信的真人秀明星。与他的家人不同，兰斯支持这个项目。他喜欢这种对自我的夸张表演的想法。我喜欢生活，你知道，带着一种风格和某种虚假的优雅。我的意思是，我能说什么呢？
The guy was very prescient. This was 1971 when they were filming it. This was way before its time. And this spoke to so many people. And in fact, it spoke to a lot of people I interviewed for this book because a lot of people, especially young gay men, who saw this guy on television, it spoke to a lot of people I interviewed for this book because a lot of people, especially young gay men, who saw this guy on television, it's very different than seeing, you know, a documentary.
这家伙非常有先见之明。他们拍摄时是1971年。这太超前了。这触动了很多人。事实上，它触动了我为这本书采访的许多人，因为很多人，尤其是年轻的男同性恋者，当他们在电视上看到这个家伙时，这与看到，你知道，一部纪录片非常不同。
There were documentaries about homosexuals or some scripted drama. Just the genuineness of him just being himself in front of the camera, I think, just flipped a switch in the culture. And people tried to replicate this for years and actually John Murray, who was the co-creator of The Real World, was 17 at the time that show came out. And when he saw Lance Loud and when he saw The Louds and American Family, it absolutely got into his head and he was like, Jesus Christ, this is unlike anything else on television. And when he made The Real World, it was part of a process by which he was seeking to replicate
有关于同性恋者的纪录片或一些有剧本的戏剧。我认为他只是在镜头前做自己的那种真实感，在文化中拨动了一个开关。人们多年来一直试图复制这一点，实际上《真实世界》的联合创作者约翰·默里（John Murray）在那档节目播出时才17岁。当他看到兰斯·劳德，看到《劳德一家》和《美国家庭》时，它完全进入了他的脑海，他想，天哪，这与电视上的任何其他东西都不同。当他制作《真实世界》时，这是他寻求复制
the power of that show. You know, this is my period of aliveness. It's between Americans and Americans. Yeah, it's like all Gen X people, like the real world chapter, which is a linchpin central chapter in the book. It makes sense because the real world is the real world's the moment that modern reality is created. This is the true story. the moment that modern reality is created.
那档节目力量的过程的一部分。你知道，这是我的活跃期。它是在美国人和美国人之间。是的，就像所有X世代的人一样，比如《真实世界》那一章，这是书中的核心章节。这很有道理，因为《真实世界》是现代真人秀诞生的时刻。这是真实的故事。
This is the true story. True story. Seven strangers. Picked to live in a loft. And have their lives taped. To find out what happens. What? When people stop being polite.
这是真实的故事。真实的故事。七个陌生人。被选中住进一个阁楼。并把他们的生活录下来。看看会发生什么。什么？当人们不再礼貌。
Could you get the phone? And start getting real. The real world. All of these early experiments turned into something that's much more structured, a different kind of workplace, a different set of craft mechanisms. And it's very different than an American Family. And American Family was a documentary that was kind of floaty and drifty and genuinely cinema verite.
你能接个电话吗？并开始变得真实。《真实世界》。所有这些早期的实验都变成了结构更严密的东西，一种不同的工作场所，一套不同的工艺机制。这与《美国家庭》非常不同。《美国家庭》是一部纪录片，有点飘忽不定，是真正的电影真实主义。
And it was this amazing thing to watch. It was sort of like you put American Family through this quick cut MTV style edit with canted angles and constructed with all this verve and music hits and stuff. And maybe it was just the nineties, but there was this constant thread of people talking about authenticity all the time. Yeah, when you watch it again,
观看它是一种奇妙的体验。就像你把《美国家庭》通过这种MTV风格的快速剪辑，加上倾斜的角度，用所有的活力和音乐热点构建出来。也许这只是90年代，但人们一直在谈论真实性。是的，当你再次观看它时，
all they ever talk about is, am I selling out? Are you being real? Are you being fake? Are you being sexy to try to be commercial? Like it's full of extremely passionate and sometimes kind of funny conversations about the anxiety about whether they're being fake. It's a time capsule is all I can say. And I talked to all of the seven people who were on the show, but I also talked to John Murray who co-created it with Mariella Spunum and all of the crew. And it's a period in their life that was so heightened,
他们谈论的全部就是，我是在出卖自己吗？你是真实的吗？你是虚假的吗？你是为了商业而表现得性感吗？它充满了关于是否虚假的焦虑的极其热情，有时甚至有点有趣的对话。我只能说它是一个时间胶囊。我采访了节目中的所有七个人，我也采访了与玛丽埃拉·斯普纳姆（Mariella Spunum）共同创作它的约翰·默里以及所有的工作人员。这是他们生命中一个非常高涨的时期，
specifically because of this argument, is this a game show or is this a documentary? Are we tricking people or are we trying to capture something true about them? So I want to talk about Survivor, which you point out is the moment when after decades of people kind of searching in the dark to come up with a solution to the same problem,
特别是因为这个争论，这是游戏节目还是纪录片？我们在捉弄人，还是在试图捕捉关于他们的真实东西？所以我想谈谈《幸存者》，你指出这是在人们经过几十年的黑暗摸索，试图找到解决同一个问题的方案之后，
which is not paying writers and actors and directors, comes together. Like all the elements were there, but people didn't really think of reality television up to this point as this fully realized genre until the early 2000s when Survivor comes along. I was just really surprised how long it took for people to land on something like Survivor. It did take decades and it's absolutely true that there was no category that people thought of as reality TV until Survivor came along. And all of these experiments that had happened before were often short-lived, high-rated, junky cultural crises that would create a moral outrage in the press. And then they would dissolve. They would come and they would go and it was a series of experiments. And
即不支付编剧、演员和导演费用的时刻，所有元素都汇聚在一起。就像所有的元素都在那里，但在《幸存者》出现之前，人们并没有真正把真人秀看作是一个完全实现的类型。我真的很惊讶人们花了这么长时间才想到像《幸存者》这样的东西。这确实花了数十年，而且绝对正确的是，在《幸存者》出现之前，没有任何类别被人们认为是真人秀。所有之前发生的实验往往是短命的、高收视率的、垃圾的文化危机，会在媒体中制造道德愤怒。然后它们就会消散。它们来了又走，这是一系列的实验。然后
then came Survivor. Day 24 on the island. Since the merger, nothing has been more important than voting strategy. The gears are churning. Nobody is safe. Survivor took like a decade to get it onto television. So it has a very strange history. I would say it actually started in Scotland on a radio show where they did this experiment where they sent people off into the wilderness holding a then popular survival guide and they would call in every day and say what had happened to them.
《幸存者》来了。岛上第24天。合并以来，没有什么比投票策略更重要的了。齿轮在转动。没有人是安全的。《幸存者》花了大约十年时间才搬上电视。所以它有一段非常奇怪的历史。我会说它实际上始于苏格兰的一档广播节目，他们做了一个实验，把人们送到荒野中，拿着当时流行的生存指南，他们每天打电话说发生了什么。
The producer from that moved to England and ended up working for a different guy, Charlie Parsons, and they did a different version of it on TV where they just sent a group of quasi-celebrities to an island again to survive for a few days. At that point, Charlie Parsons, who was the inventor of the format of Survivor, could not get it on the air. Why could they not get it on? Because there was nothing like it. Like television, especially in the US, was dramas and comedies, half-hour shows and hour-long shows, and sports and news. There was no category called reality television, and he kept going in and trying to pitch this thing and everybody was like, that's too weird, it sounds dangerous, I don't get it. And he tried many, many times and he failed. And then he got worn out and a different British producer named Mark Burnett bought it from him. And then he got worn out and a different British producer,
那个制作人搬到了英国，最终为另一个人查理·帕森斯（Charlie Parsons）工作，他们在电视上做了另一个版本，他们只是把一群准名人送到一个岛上，再次生存几天。那时，查理·帕森斯，也就是《幸存者》模式的发明者，无法让它播出。为什么他们无法让它播出？因为没有类似的东西。就像电视，特别是在美国，是戏剧和喜剧，半小时节目和一小时节目，以及体育和新闻。没有叫“真人秀”的类别，他不断去推销这个东西，每个人都说，这太奇怪了，听起来很危险，我不明白。他尝试了很多次，但都失败了。然后他精疲力竭，另一位英国制作人马克·伯内特（Mark Burnett）从他那里买下了它。
named Mark Burnett, bought it from him. And within a very short time, he sold it to CBS. I mean, it's one of those strange little quirky moments in history where had he not bought that show, I think it would have changed all of television. And that show had such a huge, huge influence. So what was it that Survivor was able to nail that other reality shows just in the past just couldn't?
马克·伯内特从他那里买下了它。在很短的时间内，他把它卖给了CBS。我的意思是，这是历史上那些奇怪的小巧合时刻之一，如果他没有买下那档节目，我想它会改变整个电视界。那档节目产生了如此巨大、巨大的影响。那么《幸存者》到底做对了什么，而过去的真人秀却做不到？
Like what was Survivor able to do? I will say straightforwardly, when I started writing this book, I wasn't that interested in Survivor. Like I had started out watching Big Brother and I thought that that was a weird, voyeuristic, fascinating experiment. And Survivor was kind of a basic show that a lot of people liked, but I just thought of it as a game show. By the time I finished my research, I was like, I need to write two chapters about Survivor. It's very important to me. And to me, what it is, is part of it is about the format of Survivor, which I ended up feeling was all of those lines that I'm talking about, the game show combination with documentary,
《幸存者》到底能做什么？我会直截了当地说，当我开始写这本书时，我对《幸存者》并不感兴趣。我开始看《老大哥》，我认为那是一个奇怪的、窥淫癖的、迷人的实验。而《幸存者》是一档很多人喜欢的简单节目，但我只是把它当作一个游戏节目。当我完成研究时，我想，我需要写两章关于《幸存者》的内容。它对我来说非常重要。对我来说，它的一部分是关于《幸存者》的模式，我最终觉得我谈论的所有那些界限，游戏节目与纪录片的结合，
the soap opera, and the prank show, are all woven together in Survivor. What the outcome was, was that it was a game show that worked like a prank show are all woven together in Survivor. What the outcome was, was that it was a game show that was worked like a prank show by putting people under pressure and taking them by surprise, but magically produced a soap opera with incredible characters, twists and turns, cliffhangers. Just an amazing outcome that caused everybody to want to imitate it. A lot of television had to change to set the stage for reality TV,
肥皂剧和恶作剧节目，都在《幸存者》中交织在一起。结果是，它是一档像恶作剧节目一样运作的游戏节目，通过把人们置于压力之下并让他们措手不及，但神奇地产生了一部带有不可思议的角色、曲折、悬念的肥皂剧。这是一个令人惊叹的结果，导致每个人都想模仿它。很多电视节目必须改变才能为真人秀搭建舞台，
but the audiences also had to change in order for Survivor to become this cultural phenomenon. Like, what was that evolution about? I'm not sure that the audience did change to watch Survivor. I think that because, you know, since the 40s throughout the 50s, 60s, and 70s, there was sort of a break in the 80s. I think audiences have always been drawn to kind of sensational things like this. The different change that I would say is that, and this is the one that John Murray from the real world says that is his major achievement, is he felt like starting with the real world,
但观众也必须改变，才能让《幸存者》成为这种文化现象。那种演变是关于什么的？我不确定观众是否为了看《幸存者》而改变了。我认为因为，你知道，从40年代到50、60和70年代，80年代有一个断层。我认为观众一直被这种耸人听闻的东西所吸引。我会说的不同变化是，这是《真实世界》的约翰·默里所说的他的主要成就，他觉得从《真实世界》开始，
they created an audience of people who grew up with these shows and preferred them to scripted shows and who understood them and who were deep fans of them, for whom they weren't gimmicks or momentary sensations, but something that they took for granted and enjoyed and, you know, created conversations about. But if the real world had set off the modern period of reality TV, Survivor is what created the industry. It was so successful, it was so beloved, it was such a huge global hit, and also it was so lucrative that everybody wanted to imitate it. And during that period, after Survivor came out into a lesser extent Big Brother, everybody tried to create the new Survivor. So what happened was
他们创造了一群伴随着这些节目长大、更喜欢它们而不是有剧本节目、理解它们并且是它们的忠实粉丝的观众，对他们来说，它们不是噱头或短暂的轰动，而是他们认为理所当然并享受的东西，你知道，并围绕它们创造对话。但如果《真实世界》开启了现代真人秀时期，《幸存者》就是创造了产业的东西。它太成功了，太受欢迎了，它是如此巨大的全球热门，而且它利润丰厚，以至于每个人都想模仿它。在那段时期，《幸存者》播出后，在较小程度上《老大哥》播出后，每个人都试图创造新的《幸存者》。所以发生的事情是
that there was this volcano of production, some bad shows, some good shows, and all sorts of mini versions of reality TV, like new mini genres, like different kinds of dating shows, different kinds of prank shows. There was a trend of militant around the time of the war where there were shows that covered that. There were celebrity shows that were a new thing, like Celeb Reality. So there was a period of experimentation where everybody essentially was trying to create the next big reality hit. And suddenly there is this explosion of new kinds of shows. You end the book, and it's almost remiss to not talk about the fact that there was a reality television start that was our
生产的火山爆发，一些糟糕的节目，一些好的节目，以及各种各样的真人秀迷你版本，比如新的迷你类型，比如不同种类的约会节目，不同种类的恶作剧节目。战争期间有一种军事趋势，有报道这些的节目。名人节目是一种新事物，比如名人真人秀。所以有一段实验时期，每个人本质上都在试图创造下一个真人秀大热门。突然之间，出现了各种新节目的爆发。你结束了这本书，如果不谈论有一个真人秀明星成为了我们的
president. Sorry, who was that? remiss to not talk about the fact that there was a reality television start that was our president. Sorry, who was that? My name is Donald Trump and I'm the largest real estate developer in New York. I own buildings all over the place, model agencies, the Miss Universe pageant, jetliners, golf courses, casinos, and have turned the name Trump into the highest quality brand. You're fired. So how is reality important to his ascendancy?
总统，几乎是失职。抱歉，那是谁？有一个真人秀明星成为了我们的总统。抱歉，那是谁？我的名字是唐纳德·特朗普，我是纽约最大的房地产开发商。我在各地拥有建筑、模特经纪公司、环球小姐选美大赛、喷气式客机、高尔夫球场、赌场，并将特朗普这个名字变成了最高质量的品牌。你被解雇了。那么真人秀对他权力的崛起有多重要？
It's a show that is marked by two things. One of them is obviously it is responsible for Trump's election. I mean, I just don't think this is ambiguous. It had the biggest and most obvious repercussion of reality TV. And so for a lot of people, it was the reason that reality TV seems so terrible is like, look what it led to. It elected Trump and it did elect Trump. So that's part of it. The other reason that I wanted it to be the final chapter though, is that it's essentially the period where
这是一个以两件事为标志的节目。其中之一显然是它导致了特朗普的当选。我的意思是，我不认为这一点有什么模棱两可的。它产生了真人秀节目最大、最明显的影响。所以对很多人来说，这就是为什么真人秀看起来如此糟糕的原因，就像看看它导致了什么结果一样。它选出了特朗普，而且确实是它选出了特朗普。所以这是其中的一部分。不过，我希望它成为最后一章的另一个原因是，它本质上是我们所讨论的实验结束的时期。
the experiments that we're talking about ended. It's the point at which reality television became less of a chaotic gonzo attempt to create a new form of television, and it was an industry. The people who made The Apprentice were making a show for network television. They were polished producers and editors. They'd done these jobs before, and they pulled off this show. And the other thing that I think is striking about that show is that show did a very, it very smartly combined two major forms of reality television that had emerged during the sort
我们所谈论的实验结束了。在这一点上，真人秀电视不再是一种创造新电视形式的混乱、疯狂的尝试，而是一个行业。《学徒》的制作人是在为电视网制作节目。他们是精明的制片人和编辑。他们以前做过这些工作，并且成功地制作了这个节目。我认为该节目令人瞩目的另一件事是，它非常聪明地结合了在Survivor之后那种火山爆发式的制作浪潮中出现的两种主要的真人秀形式。
of volcanic explosion of production after Survivor. One of them is the Survivor-like show with two teams that compete and the other one is the talent contest, like American Idol or Project Runway. And so that was a Survivor-like show that was also a talent contest except that the talent instead of being ballroom dancing or fashion production is marketing. And so it's the show that demonstrates the professionalization of reality television as an industry and also the centrality of advertising and marketing. And the accomplishment of the show was to place a product named Donald Trump, who was
其中之一是像Survivor那样有两支队伍竞争的节目，另一种是像《美国偶像》或《天桥风云》那样的才艺竞赛。所以那是一个既像Survivor又像才艺竞赛的节目，只不过才艺不是交谊舞或时装制作，而是市场营销。因此，这个节目展示了真人秀作为一种行业的专业化，以及广告和营销的核心地位。该节目的成就是将一个名为唐纳德·特朗普的产品，一个失败的产品，置于节目的中心，对他进行重塑品牌，并推向世界。这就是为什么今年十一月，美国人要告诉卡玛拉·哈里斯，卡玛拉，我们受够了。我们再也受不了了。你做得太糟糕了。卡玛拉同志，你被解雇了，滚出去。你被解雇了，你不行。所以当我想到唐纳德·特朗普的崛起时，
a failed product at the center of the show, and rebrand him and set him off to the world. That's why this November Americans are going to tell Kamala Harris, Kamala, that we've had enough. We can't take it anymore. You're doing a terrible job. Comrade Harris, you're fired, get out of here. You're fired, you're no good. So when I think about the rise of Donald Trump,
我想到了一系列不幸的事件和糟糕的决定，这些本可以阻止这场完全可以避免的灾难，从有人决定真正给这家伙一个电视节目开始。我认为《学徒》带来了如此令人难以置信的灾难性后果，我当然希望它没有走到那一步。这有点难以想象。我的意思是，最初那个节目被拒绝了，因为有些人认为特朗普作为一个主角是一个令人不快的角色。
I think about the series of unfortunate events and bad decisions that could have stopped this totally stoppable disaster, starting with someone making the decision to actually give this guy a television show. I think The Apprentice has had such incredibly disastrous outcomes that of course I wish that it had not come to that. It's sort of hard to imagine. I mean, initially that show was turned down because some people thought that Trump was an unpleasant character as a main character.
但事实是，Survivor在当时非常成功，所以如果马克·伯内特想制作一个有唐纳德·特朗普的节目，它就一定会制作出来。所以你真的无法改写。我真正希望的是稍微不同的事情。我希望当特朗普参选时，政治媒体已经知道如何认真地谈论真人秀电视。因为我确实认为有两种思想流派，其中一种是对它一无所知，并说，这是破坏性的垃圾，我讨厌它。
But the truth is Survivor was so successful at that point that if Mark Burnett wanted to make a show with Donald Trump, it was going to get made. Like, so you can't really write. The thing I wish is actually slightly different. I wish that when Trump was running that the political press had known how to talk seriously about reality television. Because I do think that there are sort of two schools of thought, one of which is to know nothing about it and to say, this is damaging garbage and I hate it.
而另一面是一种罪恶的快感。这很有趣，我是个粉丝，不需要深入思考。我希望人们能深思熟虑地看待它，这意味着你可以看到它积极的突破性元素，也可以认真对待它在经济和政治上造成的伤害。问题是，当特朗普参选时，我认为人们把他的这份简历视为一种乐趣，一个笑话。即使他们，你知道，无论他们是否喜欢真人秀电视，
And the other side is a kind of, it's a guilty pleasure. It's a fun, I'm a fan, and not to think about it too deeply. And I want people to regard it thoughtfully, which means that you can see the positive breakthrough elements of it and you can take seriously the harm that it's done economically and politically. The problem is when Trump was running, I think people regarded this part of his resume as fun, as a joke. Even if they, you know, whether they liked or didn't like reality television, it was
都很难想象它会有这么大的影响。事实是，当人们投票给他时，他们投票给的是他在那个节目中扮演的那个角色。这是有史以来最成功的剪辑和造假形式之一。如果媒体没有如此轻描淡写地对待它呢？我的意思是，这是我怀疑的一个转折点，如果他们真的更认真地对待特朗普本人和这个节目，是否可能会有一种理解他所作所为影响的报道。我的意思是，这太有趣了，因为当你写历史书时，这是真的。
hard to imagine that it could have such a big impact. The reality was when people voted for him, they voted for the guy he played on that show. And it was one of the most successful forms of editing and fakery that ever happened. And had the press not treated it so lightly? I mean, that's the one turning point at which I wonder if they had actually taken Trump himself and the show more seriously if there might have been a kind of coverage that understood the effects of what he was doing. I mean, it's so funny because when you're writing a history book, it's true.
就像有很多不同的时期，人们做出的选择，你想要重写它。绝对是这样。休息之后，艾米丽将最后一次抨击《单身汉》，几十年来它一直是收视率最高的真人秀系列之一。它非常受欢迎，以至于你或你的家人现在很可能就在某个《单身汉》群聊中。但艾米丽·努斯鲍姆说，你可能应该谨慎观看这类节目。《单身汉》是这本书中最卑劣的章节，它真正触及了
Like there are many different periods where the choice people made, you would like to rewrite it. Absolutely. After the break, Emily goes on one last tear about The Bachelor has been one of the highest rated reality series for decades. It's popular enough that there's a good chance you or a member of your family is in some sort of Bachelor group text as we speak. But Emily Nussbaum says you should probably watch these kinds of shows with caution. The Bachelor, which is by far the scummiest chapter of this book, it really gets at the
制片人能做的邪恶事情，以及正如我所谈论的工作场所的创造，其中一部分是工作场所的道德准则以及什么是被认为可以接受的。在制作约会节目中被认为可以接受的事情，我认为普通世界中的大多数人会认为是犯罪，当然只是道德上的腐败。老实说，我认为约会节目比其他节目更糟糕。很多真人秀制片人都同意我的观点。我会问他们，你喜欢做什么样的节目？什么对你来说是底线？很多真人秀制片人都同意我的观点。我会问他们，你喜欢做什么样的节目？什么对你来说是底线？
evil things that producers can do and the way in which as I'm talking about the creation of a workplace, part of that is the ethic of a workplace and what's considered acceptable. And what was considered acceptable in making dating shows is something that I think most people in the regular world would consider criminal and certainly just morally corrupt. Honestly, I think there's something worse about dating shows than other shows. And a lot of reality producers agreed with me. I would ask them, what kind of show do you like to do? What crosses the line for you? A lot of reality producers agreed with me. I would ask them, what kind of show do you like to do? What crosses the line for you?
他们中的很多人说是约会节目。他们只是觉得每个人都喝得太醉了，女孩们太脆弱了，而且你在处理人们的私人情感。但我认为，对于观看这些节目的人来说，了解它们是如何制作的很重要。我认为他们成为节目参与者的盟友很重要，
A lot of them said dating shows. They just felt like everybody was so drunk, the girls are so vulnerable, and you're dealing with people's private emotions. But the techniques on those shows, I think that it's important for people who watch them to understand how they're made. I think it's important for them to be allies
而不是制片人的盟友。因为你需要明白他们处于非常脆弱的位置。他们必须签署这些可怕的保密协议。他们不允许谈论节目是如何制作的。如果演员或工作人员的条件有任何改善，我觉得观众必须从更同情的角度来看待它。这些节目的制作越透明，人们就越能真正地对自己的观看行为做出道德决定，也就能对他们在世界上支持什么做出决定，包括我认为会改善人们处境的法律和劳工变革，
of the people who are on the shows, not of the producers. Because you need to understand that they are in very vulnerable positions. They have to sign these terrible NDAs. They're not allowed to talk about how the show is made. And if there's going to be any improvement in the conditions for cast or crew, I feel like the audience has to see it from a more sympathetic perspective. The more illuminated the making of these shows is, the more people can actually make ethical decisions about their own viewing and also just about what they support in the world, including legal and labor changes that I think will improve the circumstances with people
如果你声称喜欢这些节目，你就应该喜欢制作它们的人，并希望他们得到更好的对待。阿门。艾米丽，非常感谢你的书。我读得非常愉快，也非常感谢你参加这个节目。EM – 谢谢你邀请我。和你谈话真是太棒了。AMT – 艾米丽·努斯鲍姆的书叫《Cue the Sun》，真人秀的发明。
that if you claim to love the shows, you should love the people who make them and want them to be treated better. Amen. Emily, thank you so much for the book. I enjoyed reading it so much and thank you so much for being on the show. EM – Thank you for having me. It was wonderful talking to you. AMT – Emily Nussbaum's book is called Cue the Sun, the invention of reality TV.
书中有很多我们没有涉及的内容。我强烈建议你去看看。这是一本非常有趣的书。本周的《99% Invisible》由Vivian Lay制作，Nina Potok编辑，Hizik bin Ahmad Farid混音。音乐由Swan Riau创作。Kathy Tu是我们的执行制片人。Kurt Kolstad是数字总监。Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。
And there was a ton of stuff in the book that we didn't get to. I highly suggest you check it out. It's a really fun read. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian Lay and edited by Nina Potok, mixed by Hizik bin Ahmad Farid. Music by Swan Riau. Kathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor.
团队的其他成员包括Chris Berube、Jason DeLeon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Gabriella Gladney、Christopher Johnson、Lashima Dawn、Martine Gonzalez、Jacob Maldonado Medina、Kelly Prime、Joe Rosenberg，以及我，Roman Mars。99%的标志是由Stefan Lawrence创作的。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分，现在总部位于北边六个街区的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。
The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Christopher Johnson, Lashima Dawn, Martine Gonzalez, Jacob Maldonado Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful Uptownown Oakland, California.
你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，以及我们全新的Discord服务器。有近5000人在讨论建筑、讨论《权力掮客》、讨论旗帜、讨论播客推荐。这是我最近待得最多的地方。你可以在99PI.org找到该链接以及99PI的每一期往期节目。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our brand new Discord server. There's almost 5,000 people talking about architecture, talking about Power Broker, talking about flags, talking about podcast recommendations. It's where I'm hanging out most these days. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.